bien vous êtes fret vous n'êtes qu'un
grand mère de christian vadim s'appelait
ardilouze et benoît haute de verdun
entendu ça reste un dernière dans
l'émission et il m'a envoyé un mail avec
une idée d'interviews qui s'appelle
l'ardilouse
bon alors dit lou sait que les trucs de
luz votre pire passage télé à part suis
là ce soir c'était le dernier
très bien votre pire cuite jamais j'ai
une phobie du vomi donc jamais je me
fait mal c'est bien ça c'est bizarre
c'est une chance ban
est ouest et quand l'agent prentiss
toujours ce soir bien et vous je vous
demande pas c'était la veille de la demi
finale vous avez vu le résultat rien a
vu le résultat bien votre pire mais avec
sophie piermay cas d'incendié ouais bah
ça serait ça c'est xavier de fontenay
dans ce serait qui pire de tout ça
serait celui avec eux on apprendrait que
qu'il a déjà quelqu'un
ça vous est arrivé ça déjà ce qui t'as
fait ça c'est un mec de la télé ça n'en
arrête arrête
non mais si basse laurence à mèze un mec
de la télé non mais très connu
de pires souvenirs
pierre de vos choix
et ses ministres comme si d'un côté le
l'hôtel campanile avec madoff antennes
un nom un truc bon c'est pas vraiment
pire mais elle est l'événement on se
demande qu'est ce qui suit va quoi
c'était comme un salon se pacsant dans
l'agriculture mais c'était une femme le
storm pirelli au sol en a donné toute sa
vie non mais on était dans la boue il
faisait super froid et le jeu au milieu
des vaches ses apports au glacier
abandonner
votre pire expérience homosexuelle
y en a pas ça très réussi mais je peux
en a pas et donc savourer
votre pire moment avec geneviève de
fontenay
bassesse était en fait on n'était pas
ensemble mais c'est ce qui s'est passé
de parts après la sortie du livre tout
ce qui a été dit c'est un moment assez
dur à vivre le moment le plus moyen de
toute la carrière maintenant
[Musique]
vous avez raté combien de fois votre
permis de conduire j'ai eu du premier
coup 18 ans la tenue la plus moche que
vous ayez jamais porté sauf là on parle
pas d'eux parle plus du lapin mais le
pire émission de télé que vous ayez fait
c'est pas chez vous voir la chance est
gentil le plus mauvais livres que vous
ayez jamais lui livre le dernier de
roland dumas a le dernier de roland
dumas allez vous a pas plu comment
s'appelle je suis même plus j'oublie je
serais plutôt bof c'est pas mal
c'est aussi bien que vous n'avez pas est
une merde pareille le plus mauvais
livres que vous ayez écrit
le premier 1
la [ __ ] d'un public sur la personne
qui vous a fait le plus de mal on va pas
leur cité tout le temps c'est lui je
croyais pas ce g 2
[Musique]
sonia quel a été le pire moment de votre
vie
qui était loin de quitter au rwanda le
burundi l'insultent quand vous balance
le plus souvent
dans des lettres c'est la grèce voilà
votre histoire d'amour la plus naze
l'avant dernière ah oui c
est j en parle pas et moi non non non ah
bon non mais l'avant dernière c'est
assez précis quand même un bain la
dernière il vient la semaine prochaine
donc tu veux ouais
le plus mauvais souvenirs d'école que
vous ayez
la risée à cluny en bourgogne ouais
c'était pas facile il fallait que je
m'adapte à cette nouvelle culture était
pas passé des éléphanteaux skarabot
c'est la pire chose que vous ayez fait
en étant bourré d'avoir voulu grand mon
père bah oui c'est lui qui m'a bourré ce
jour là dont bon nombre
est tombé à l'eau et bien d'autres
sasken l agonie 120
le moment la corde
la personne qui a fait le plus de mal
je dirais
oui j'aimerais bien
t'as pas les couilles seule touche
allait bien je ne ferai pas nous mêmes
les changements
temps prendra lé là vient le nom ils
arrêtent pas de râler qui se fait chez
les jeunes
quel talent
planck que je suis lente [ __ ] de
placard la mettais pas bien non et
pourquoi non non je veux pas de gros
plan attends je suis pas venu pour tes
conneries là je suis venu pour le
sidaction attends tu permets que je
termine ma dame ah bah non c'est
joliment dit c'est plus simple c'est
joliment dit c'est beaucoup plus
important ce qu'il va dire non d'aller
tout de suite après la personne qui vous
a fait le plus de mal dans votre vie à
part richard bohringer ce soir non c'est
mon erreur de casting dernièrement avec
le avec les le pire endroit où vous ayez
habité pire en noir
non en fait le pire endroit où j'ai vécu
c'est peut-être au burundi pendant la
période du du massacre parce que on dort
pas tous les jours et on je passe aussi
bien pour le croit voilà votre pire
émission de télévision
font dix mois celle que je retrouve
souvent si celle-là bon ouais mais ça
s'est pas mal passé non toujours tous
très bien et d'ailleurs merci
combien de fois avez vous ratez votre
permis de conduire
première fois aux [ __ ] tout leur
réussit j'en peux plus
quelle est la tenue la plus moche que
vous ayez jamais porté
bien j'étais mannequin donc
le cadeau le plus moche que vous ayez
reçu à part les fleurs au mcdo elle
je crois que
c'était un impie demain en la côte est
qui était très moche et nous regardent
bonsoir débat motifs dessus wayne unger
énorme géant
combien de gens n'y a pas que les
meneurs pieds noirs qui font des piloris
la pire chose que vous ayez fait diane
en étant ivre à
j'ai volé un bateau ah oui c'est
beaucoup qui veulent abattre
à venise à venise faisait voler un
bateau mais je te partie avec une
gondole ouais t'as 4h du mat la police
derrière moi quelle est la personne qui
vous a fait le plus de mal dans votre
vie
ah je dirais moi même bien joué bien
jouer
d'armand apprécié mais mélasse ménélas
apprécié le nail art elle est bien celle
des 3 janvier l'émission de télé que
vous ayez jamais fait écoutez vous êtes
la deuxième donc je veux pas on n'est
que la deuxième mais je sais qu'il aime
bien c'était tps star mag ou je sais pas
quoi vous partez où la g part à londres
et bétonner pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux